being a mackerel snapping papist I
rarely have the opportunity to encounter
the woke Protestant askers who sometimes
make the rounds on social media being an
adult man I very rarely see anything on
Tick Tock I really only see it when my
producers bring these videos to me chill
out man what's your problem you you're
my problem but my producer Mr Ben Davies
is a Protestant and frequently on Tick
Tock so he has assured me I must listen
to the brilliant
theological musings of Reverend Reverend
I don't think so I don't think so
Brandon Robertson who is a noted author
activist and public Theologian as
opposed to those private theologians
working at the intersections of
spirituality sexuality and social
renewal is known as The Tick Tock Pastor
he's garnered over 200 000 followers and
five million views now speaking of
religion this video is brought to you by
hallo go to hallow.com Knowles right now
get an exclusive three months free that
is three months free at hallow.com
Knowles more from Halo in just a bit Mr
Robertson take it away that Jesus helped
his friend come out so it's been like a
year since I made this video where I
used the story of Jesus raising Lazarus
from the dead as a metaphor for Jesus
Calling LGBT people out of the closet
videos ever since Christians of course
lost their mind saying look at you
taking that passage out of context
that's not what the passage is about of
course I don't believe the story was
literally about Lazarus being gay and
coming out of the closet but for
thousands of years Christians have used
biblical stories as metaphors for other
things in our life and in our world and
I do firmly believed based on the Bible
that Jesus wants to see LGBT people step
into our full god-created identity as
queer people
Jesus wants to call us out of the
man-made closets of Shame and repression
that so many who claim the name of
Christ have forced us into to any LGBT
person struggling with their faith oh
he's a gay guy Jesus is calling you oh
got it I didn't know that but he says
it's us so I assume he's placing himself
within the LGBT umbrella
this is an amazing inversion because
Christ raises Lazarus from the dead in
this prefigures Christ's own
Resurrection but what does Christ do in
this episode with Lazarus Lazarus is
dead and then Christ brings him back to
life what Pastor Brandon over here is
suggesting though is that people go in
the opposite direction because Christ
says if you sin you are dead in sin with
it the wages of sin are death and what
Christ does is he frees us from our sin
which is death and gives us life
Everlasting by embracing all sorts of
disordered sexual behaviors one is going
in entirely the opposite direction and
pursuing what Christians have always
considered to be sin so it's a devilish
little inversion because leftism is a
false religion and it aids all of the
language of Christianity and it Apes
even many of the rituals of Christianity
but it just distorts perverts and
ultimately even inverts go ahead show me
the chapter and verse bro
go ahead here's the thing you can comb
through the thousands of verses of the
Bible and find justification for
anything you want to justify but that's
an abuse of the scripture this ancient
book does not have anything to say about
modern medical procedures like abortion
it doesn't condemn it nor does it
endorse it but what the Bible does do is
give us principles morals overarching
themes that we should apply to our
thought around these conversations
for instance the Bible says every human
being is made in the image and likeness
of God and therefore is worthy of
dignity equality respect and autonomy
over our lives
[Music]
and what they do likewise the Bible is
not a medical text so it doesn't tell us
when life begins or when personhood
begins those are questions for science
not for scripture he knows that his
argument is quite weak here so he's not
trying to twist scripture to defend his
infanticide what he's saying is listen
man we just don't know come on enough of
this Bible talk if Bible's just kind of
it leaves this issue alone but the Bible
obviously doesn't leave this issue alone
because the Bible tells us quite clearly
in the Ten Commandments that thou shalt
not commit murder kill him I shouldn't
we know that God loves the little
children we know that Christ says
whoever scandalizes a child it would be
better than have a millstone tied around
his neck there's a hubris that comes
along with these modern Libs who who
think that everyone who ever came before
them was a total dummy and they didn't
know anything about anything but no they
did people knew what babies were they
knew what pregnancy was there were
people who attempted to kill babies in
the womb to end pregnancies long before
Pastor Brandon ever came around and the
church addressed this question from the
very earliest centuries and the church
said you can't do it and the church has
been consistent on this point for 2 000
years and we see the reasoning for that
in the Bible and we can see the
reasoning for that in the natural law
and the objective moral order and we see
it consistently for two Millennia no
matter what Pastor Brandon says in the
year of Our Lord 2023. right now go to
hallow.com Knowles in a society teeming
with irreligion like the era religion
that we're hearing right now it can be
incredibly challenging to ground oneself
in what we know to be true and good
choose today to embrace your faith and
start building a habit of prayer join me
and thousands of others on hallow the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States hallow is helping everyone
to maintain a daily prayer routine it
can help you download the app for free
at hallow.com Knowles you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start how
about you check out my favorite podcast
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
available on the Hallow app for brief
daily readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg and Jonathan
Rumi who portrays Jesus in The Chosen
with hello you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions download Hello at
hello.com Knowles get an exclusive three
months free that is three months
absolutely free at hallow.com Knowles
despite your name calling I'll answer
your question there is not a single
condemnation in all of the Bible of
pre-marital sex
[Music]
there is a mistranslation in the New
Testament of the Greek word pornea into
the Old English word fornication which
does in fact mean premarital sex but if
you look up the Greek word pornea it
does not neatly translate to fornication
it's a mistranslation pornea in Greek is
what we would call a junk drawer word
that means all sorts of sexual
immorality and that category of what is
sexually immoral is different based on
what culture or values you have so there
is no clear condemnation of premarital
sex in the Bible now yes I do believe
lust is a sin lust is when you objectify
another person you strip them of their
humanity and make them an object of your
sexual gratification that is condemned
in the Bible because the Bible tells us
to treat every human with full dignity
and respect so that is why lust is
condemned this is the most coherent
thing I've heard this guy say he points
out that pornea is a difficult word to
translate and it doesn't neatly
translate into any specific sexual
category that we we use in English and
that's true
now he comes to the wrong conclusion he
says and because we know that sexual
immorality is contingent on one's
culture we know that today presumably
because our culture approves of
premarital sex the premarital sex is not
a sin that's where he goes wrong because
sexual morality is not contingent on
one's culture or on one's own personal
views but it's objective it's
established by God and so once we've
figured that out we realize that
premarital sex is in fact immoral but
then we can take it further as Pastor
Brandon is pointing at and say actually
all sorts of sexual activities are
immoral as well that sex has a purpose
just like our bodies have a purpose like
our marriages have a purpose when we
twist those things away from their
purpose or to undermine their purpose
then things go awry talk about twisting
the Bible to fit your own agenda Jesus
never said that marriage is between a
man and a woman what you're referring to
is a passage in which Jesus was asked a
specific question about a specificity
about marriage he was asked by one of
the teachers of the law if it was lawful
for a man to divorce his wife he was
asked a question about heterosexual
marriage and he responds also known as
marriage adopt that heterosexual
marriage he quotes from the book of
Genesis and says a man must leave his
father mother and cling to his wife and
the Two Become One flesh therefore
divorce
a sin
Jesus was condemning the divorce of a
heterosexual couple he was never asked
about marriage between two people of the
same gender because that's not possible
[Music]
he kind of undermines his own Point here
because he says what Christ is referring
to can be seen in the Book of Genesis
when marriage is described as the union
between a man and a woman oh whoops I
wasn't supposed to say that Jesus was
asked a specific question about marriage
in specific terms and so he refers to an
earlier description in the Bible about
how marriage is between a man and a
woman oh Whoopsie Daisy
[Music]
at the time of our Lord's sojourn on
Earth and for all manner of Millennia
before then no one anywhere seriously
believed that marriage could exist
between two men or two women lesbians
marriage was understood for all of that
time until about uh I don't know like
2015 to be about sexual difference the
union of man and woman as coupling
complementary human beings for the good
of the spouses and for the sake of the
generation and education of children and
so to try to apply this scripture to
LGBT marriage in relationship is to take
it out of its context and to twist its
meaning stop twisting the Bible yes stop
please please stop twisting the Bible
sorry Pastor Brandon would be happy to
have him on the show though to discuss
these things until then I'm Michael
Knowles see you next time maybe
minorities sexual and gender minorities
have something to teach the church